Emrhys Cooper, Writer/Director/Actor/Producer:
We blocked out the shoot dates, we blocked
out the post-production, this is before we even
started writing any of the screenplays so
we'd already had a whole plan in place.
Film Courage: What were the steps you went
through from being an actor to becoming now
a storyteller/screenwriter? What
changed? Did anything really change?
Emrhys: A lot has changed and I’d
say for the better as I felt…what's
the word…just being an actor I never felt very
secure because I felt as I said earlier always
at the mercy of opportunities coming to me and
being cast whereas you know writing a screenplay
and being a director you're taking control of
your career and it was really hard to get there
but I just really knew that the story
that I wanted to get behind was something
that should be out there and it was very
challenging getting the investors and the
putting it all together because I wore many hats
in this one I was a producer director writer actor
I even made lunch at times I was even a gaffer
what I had to be you know I did everything I
even cleaned the toilets when they backed up I was
I mean literally I did it all but I just felt that
you know it was my first project and you know not
people weren't making that much money so whatever
I could do to make it better for everyone I did
I believe we're all equal on a film set you know
the right with the runners no different I would
listen to them all and I think that I tried to
create a very like comfortable happy environment
where people could shine in any everything they
were doing every I wanted every department to
shine and it was quite hard for me at first to
navigate that because I didn't necessarily know
what every department was supposed to be doing
so I had to kind of learn very quickly because
you need the ship to be seamless you need to run
it and you need to know what everyone's doing so
that kind of took me a little time to figure out
I'm still figuring that out because
it's very detailed and but I think that
having respect for everyone and like really
letting them do their job is important so
having the knowledge of being an actor and being
on set for so many years as an actor as a dancer
you know I kind of was always watching as I said
before I'm a very inquisitive person so I was
always even when I was acting or dancing on sets
I was always interested what everyone was doing
and then when you're a director it's your job to
know what everyone's doing because if someone's
not doing their job properly you need to make
sure they are so it's a difficult role sometimes
because you're you know you'll sometimes
have people that have different opinions
but at the end of the day it's your vision
and you need to come from a place of love and
make express that and that's one thing else i've
i've learned how to express from your heart rather
than say this is wrong if you can really inspire
with your word it's going to be so much better
right and especially when you're in a high
pressure situation like you have to make your day
and you only have so many days left and certain
pages of the script haven't been covered and
things like that I'm sure it's it's harder
to come from your heart in those moments but
yeah what makes your writing process different
than others having a background in dancing
and performing having that kind of detailed
regime where you're literally in the studio
as a dancer you're in the studio at 8am you're
leaving at 8pm it's a really hard schedule so
I always knew what you had to have a work ethic
to be a dancer or be a professional performer you
can't just phone it in so I kind of applied that
to when I became when I started my endeavors as
a writer I made sure I took it really seriously
I blocked off you know two or three months five
days a week I treated it like a job if you treat
it like a job as a job I didn't treat it like a
hobby I knew with the sure process I actually
speak to a life coach so before we even I just
I told her the whole thing and she said well how
are you going to make this movie so we actually
planned the whole year from we blocked out how
long it would take to write the script we blocked
out time to raise investment we blocked out the
pre-production we blocked out the shoot dates
we blocked out the post-production this is before
we even started writing any of the screenplays so
we'd already had a whole plan in place so and then
we actually stuck to it and literally everything
happened and if it hadn't if we I think having
that full plan really helped stick to a schedule
because otherwise you could be writing a script
for a year and then you know how long is a piece
of string and then it's just one of these things
that's just a never-ending thing so I think having
an end goal and having a real schedule having a
plan then you can execute the plan you can hold
yourself accountable to the plan and I think I
mean I treat that with everything I do I try and
have a whole game plan in place of how I'm gonna
do it so you had a life coach help you plan out
a film about not so much life coaches but gurus
interesting that's fascinating my life coach in
fact is an amazing woman Sarah Alexander who
in fact is a story consultant on The Shuroo
Process because she's been to a lot of the
retreats and she has first-hand experience
with subject matter so she was actually very very
helpful in me creating the beats to the screenplay
before writing the screenplay she helped
me understand the types of characters that
would go there why they would go there and she
actually experienced a lot of the things that
occurred over the weekend so yeah it was really
helpful having a consultant that really knew the
world more than I did and then she helped me just
really stay on track and I think you know it's
having a real plan will make it so much easier
to navigate if you don't really have a plan
then it's harder to kind of you know know where
you're at so I think whatever project you do it's
really good to have like an idea of how you're
going to execute it and who you want to involve
yourself with and the timeline of how to how to do
it did she give you homework and say when you come
back to me we need to have this done she gives me
a lot of homework actually it's really challenging
talking to her because she really pushes me she
you know every we speak once we still actually
we still work together we're working together
right now we're working on some other projects
and it's exhausting she really pushes me she asked
me questions that I have like a very in-depth
profound things I hadn't really thought about
and challenges me to like understand the purpose
of why people should be watching this and why I
should be telling this story and it's been really
helpful I think everyone should have someone
whether it's a life coach or or someone that can
that can believe in them inspire them also push
them it's great to have that figure in your life
I think right and so you would come back with
completed pages and would you actually review them
with her so she lives in the uk and it was funny
so we've been working together for four years we
actually did trophy boy together she's actually
been one of the most instrumental people in my
becoming this director of coming this this new
journey I'm going on she's one of the people
that's really helped me navigate it and see how
I can do it but yeah so i'd send her pages weekly
and she would give me her notes and she was very
involved with as well with the screenplay and the
edit of the movie and now since the release that's
now the release we're talking about like you know
pr ideas and marketing so it's been really
cool been really interesting so she saw the
rough cut won your editor she saw every graph
cut said she saw probably like ten cuts yeah
fascinating that's that's actually great really
grateful to her yeah to have a coach that's
kind of holding you accountable in some way you
know like a sponsor or something almost but yeah
but not maybe in the same vein but and she really
wants the film to you know whilst fame money and
acclaim are great I just really want the
audience to emotionally connect to the film
and come away with something and that's what we
we we really like fine tune what is the intention
for the audience to come away with why should
they invest an hour and a half of their life in
the project so those key questions are
things that I think every filmmaker should
ask themselves when they're making a film or a
show you know why is the audience watching it
well sure and I think what I came away with is
about trust and it's not just about trusting
someone else to help you about trusting
yourself as new age as that sounds but
you know because there are moments where
Declan [played by Donal Brophy] asks a lot
from these participants and and they trust in
him and then I think trusting in yourself was
probably the biggest lesson yeah yeah awesome
I'm glad you got that yeah and stripping away
the mask and the onion and getting to the core
of you is actually where healing can begin
right I like the one character forgive me his
name wasn't mark was it it was the one that who
was taking care of his mother monk okay mark yeah
I liked him because you know he was so quiet and
you knew there was something very deep brewing and
he was kind of off to the side a lot of the time
I know the main character was too but he wouldn't
let people in and and I think there was something
very interesting you knew that there was a lot
of some deep waters in there I guess for lack
of a better term I'm glad that you saw that yeah
it's not what he's saying it's how you're seeing
you show not tell so that was kind of the goal
with mark so I'm glad you felt that thank you.
What do you like about this video?